In Europe there is 1 country to which no one travels,
1 territory with 1 Rich history and culture
which was conquered by Alexander the Great,
the Vincentians and the Ottomans
and in World War II,
when it looked like they were going to be pending,
became part of Yugoslavia.
Finally in 1991 they declared themselves independent,
but his name generated 1 great tension with his neighboring country,
Greece,
since there was also 1 region here called the same
Macedonia.
In 2019 they had to change their name and flag
for North Macedonia,
although if you ask the Macedonians themselves
are not very happy with the change.
In addition to being 1 country with 1 rich history of culture,
is also a country with landscapes
impressive
and is home to the third oldest lake in the world.
Although if you want to know more about Macedonia,
the best places,
the ideal route,
how to get to the country and how to move around in a complete way
independent,
let me know in the comments for 1/2